did edfaust really beat me the other day
i'd fast oh from position oh advanced
beat me let's get revenge
i'm also curious oh it's a traxler
it's a oh i'm white ah i wa
so if i play against a traxxar
i prefer to take with bishop so i don't
get mated instantly
this is kind of scary which platform has
been the most rewarding
they're different in different ways
yeah it's it's hard to like pick one
over the other i mean youtube
youtube definitely has a larger it's
just a larger platform in general is it
my move
oh it's my move oh free queen i was
waiting for black to play a move because
this is like the main
it's a mainline position but my my
opponent customized the position they
forgot to set it to black to move
that's so funny
we both thought it was black's move
you'll have to send me another challenge
oh game of boredom oh
i won a queen and then opponent aborts
our glorious leader ah i'm forced into a
traxler
i don't even man what's the line
i don't even traxler bro
i mean king f1 seems illogical i know
i'm supposed to take and then do
something
i'm scared my opponent's booked up but
yolo
thanks for subbing in james bond
11. i'm thinking king e3 how bad is this
i play king e3 black's still
forked and the knights hanging and then
maybe i can win king of the hill
[Music]
i mean there's queen h4 oh it's 302
man so i i have no time to like think
thoroughly
i know there's some other lines but king
e3 seems like the move my opponent would
be least prepared for
ah opponents prepared i have this move
oh there's knight g3
and if i take the rook oh queen f4 is
coming ooh
this is a nasty opening
i should i should try this someday
i mean i might as well go for this line
and pray
if it takes i think i can get away with
taking the real queen d4 king f3
king of three here there's rook f oh
there's counseling oh this is probably
prep
this is almost certainly prep wow what a
move
i'm scared i'm also maybe getting mated
kind of this move
this is rough this move
how do i not lose instantly
ah the bishop's coming in too wow what a
move
and this move
i'm so down on time as well my up
material
what's material i'm up a bishop for two
pawns but i'm about to lose a bishop
that was such a strong opening let's
move castling
forgot it was legal but thankfully i'm
threatening the queen trade
and the queen doesn't have a weight oh
it does oh
i i can't now this is a mate threat
i wanted to take but this is made in two
queen f3 is also i'm queen d1 maybe
so the goal is just to survive
hello hello
please help me actually don't help me i
can i can do this
alone maybe
i just have two goals don't get mated
and don't get flagged
okay let's uh opponent wants to mate me
again
oh we couldn't do a little draw maybe we
could repeat
we had this position twice already
i'd be i'd be thrilled with a draw
oh okay so we're trading
um i have to stop bishop f3
it's still a difficult position though
play this move i'm losing pawns all over
the place
let's trade at least i'm down about 50
seconds
oh that's a good move i not get forked
that was a really good move
i have to play king g2 i guess ctrl f3
and then bishop d2
opponent's bullet rating oh opponent
doesn't oh does play bullets
no doesn't play bullets that's only
blitz okay
so i have some hope
ah okay opponent miss knight c2 winning
winning material
e5 is now hanging
rookie 7 i play this move
okay
let's win a pawn
my time my beautiful time am i meeting
not quite meeting it was close to mate
let's go
oh i was so
close to flagging there oh
i was really close i was like a
near-death experience
thanks for the game
thanks for the bits let's go
let's go yeah
i mean this opening was actually really
incredible like really impressive
i was just i was probably toast but
somehow i didn't get mated
and i didn't flag i wonder has this been
played before this castling move
really ben feingold had this position
that's so funny
john stone glenn or glenn johnstone
against benjamin feingold
1992 i was before i was born
[Music]
wow ben feingold was 24-90 before i was
born
that's crazy
oh so castling castling equalizes
oh i had a fancy move rook h4
that's crazy i maybe should have found
that
that's a really cool idea actually to
attack the queen defend the bishop
and keep this alignment
just started med school but still
watching you in my spare time
oh and i see her play a bononi for me
one day oh
someday yeah for you and for
ben benoni's name for ben
well good luck with med school
yeah computer doesn't like this position
for white
so was king e3 of playable move
i guess it is playable this is like the
this is the one theoretical game
um so queen d4
[Music]
oh maybe castling wait this is actually
really interesting
so castling is an improvement to the ben
feingold game
wow running from finland finland
i've never been to finland well i want
to go at some point
um someday
what time is it in finland probably the
morning thank you pukselli
for the money the 470 is probably like a
normal
number of like whatever the finished
currency is
wow so i i'm assuming this is probably
some sort of theory rook h4 and then e4
check king g2
oh this is yeah this is
really crazy this requires more
extensive analysis
um but thanks for the game add fast that
was fine
i hope you're not too broken after that
this will probably go on youtube so
youtube people
hope you enjoyed that you can say hi to
twitchchat
twitchchat providing so much energy
you can follow and subscribe and watch
on twitch
link is always on in the description to
watch on twitch